the jurgen experience i think it's going
to be incredibly hard for us to
to resist the temptation to do that and
that's going to create a literal
physical barrier between human beings
i think we're all going to be living in
our own little universes eventually if
things go the way they've been going
well if i was conspiratorially minded
and i kind of am but only for fun
uh i would think that someone has
probably
set that ball in motion with kovid with
kovid and the lockdown
it's almost like if you wanted to make a
movie
where artificial intelligence wanted
to figure out a way to hook us deeper
artificial intelligence would release a
virus
and they would force us to stay inside
it doesn't kill everybody but it makes
people scared
so you stay inside and it connects you
even deeper
to computers and maybe more importantly
separates you
even more from the human experience of
touching and
being around each other in social cues
and social gathering
and it makes it even more compelling to
do things virtually
more compelling to be on your computer
all the time and messing with
applications
and then while this is all going on
something
far more immersive is released
when you're already accustomed to it
yeah i've got to say i mean
life in the last decade in particular
has has got way stranger than fiction
yeah the real world right now there is
so much about it that just seems like it
can't be real you know if anyone wrote a
movie with the script of the last
five to ten years how about the last
four here
or the last four let's pick the last
four people would say this is this isn't
yeah it's not it's nonsense like
whatever it's kind of be great hollywood
stuff that we're looking at here
um but you know the interesting thing
about this pandemic period for me is i
think it might have a weird backlash
effect where
we've all been forced to to spend time
on screens
um it's instead of going to the screen
because we we
love it and we're attracted to social
media and
whatever other things we're doing on
screens a lot of us are being forced to
use them
and one thing that's changed is
sentiment towards screens i think a lot
of people are just over it
and so when we are past all of this i
think there's a chance that's going to
be the catalyst to push people away from
screens a bit
because if you you know before this if
you were you speak to especially younger
people they'll say
and then this is true for me too i would
rather just use the most remote form of
communication possible whatever's
easiest i don't have to speak on the
phone
i don't want to have to see people let
me just send a quick text or an email or
whatsapp or whatever
and i think there's a shift now where
people are like craving
that that true face-to-face time where
you're actually sitting in front of a
person having a real conversation
and and that's that's been i think a
shift in the last
roughly eight or nine months i think
there's people like
you that are craving the experience of
being around
other folks because i think you're aware
of the repercussions of this virtual
experience that we're all
engaging in and the addiction to screens
and screen time and phones and games and
applications but i think there's plenty
of folks that are happy
to just get lulled to sleep and sucked
into it and i think that's my real
concern my real concern is
mindful thoughtful people like yourself
that are you know
that are saying listen we need you know
just a real experience with human beings
and
we're revolting and leaving the but
if you look at the numbers in terms of
human beings like what like
the average screen time all that stuff's
going up
the use of these things is all going up
and i think there's folks like you
that would like to think that we're
rejecting it but i think it's a
it's a minority that's rejecting it i
think the minori
the majority are embracing yeah i it i
i think that that may be true i mean i
think one of the big drivers of screen
time
uh is you know if you take psychological
needs away from people the things that
are really important to them to function
psychologically
that's when they turn to screens that's
when they turn to drugs that's when they
turn to alcohol that's when they turn to
all the things that
soothe us and screens do that they are a
kind of
a non-substance way to to be soothed
um that's what happened with me on that
flight for six hours
that's what happens when you're on
social media scrolling mindlessly when
you're watching tons and tons of videos
online all that sort of stuff is
is is a way of soothing you and i think
people need to be
soothed more than ever right now because
this is a
hard time for a lot of people it's hard
financially it's hard because you're
socially distant from people
um it's it's just it just creates this
kind of pool of uncertainty that sits
above everything we do
and humans hate that we don't like
uncertainty we don't like not knowing
what's coming around the corner
and not just about the pandemic i mean
politically in a lot of different ways
there's a lot of uncertainty
right now and for the last while and
when you put people in that state
they're going to turn to screens i don't
know if that's
an enduring thing but anytime you rob
people of well-being of some sort of
psychological
need they're going to try to find it
elsewhere and one of the ways they do
that is
now the easiest way to do it is to turn
to a screen
episodes of the joe rogan experience are
now free on spotify
that's right they're free from september
1st to december 1st they're going to be
available everywhere but after december
1st they will only be
available on spotify but they will be
free that includes the video the video
will also be there
it'll also be free that's all we're
asking just go download spotify
much love